do you guys think that
men are respected in society
why women no
no my other man yeah but by women no
I think they are they are yeah
I think um
I think that they are respected due to
the the position that they hold and the
amount of things that they do for the
society as a whole I think they are
perspected do you think most women are
aware how much men do for society as a
whole no
so then how are we they respect it if
women don't generally know that and they
make up the majority of society so 55
I'd say that a lot of women do respect
men I think speaking to your mic sorry I
think say most women don't respect men
is a
a bit of a higher number to say but I
think a majority of women that want a
man do respect a man there's a lot of
women that say for example for example
like
very heavy like feminists they don't
think that men some of them don't think
men deserve there was as much respect as
do you think most women let their do you
think what most women in relationships
let their husbands lead
I think they should and I'm asking what
they do
um
like they respect him enough to trust
his authority well if you're in a
relationship then yeah you should
respect it I'm not asking sure I'm
asking what is
I don't know I don't have the answers
your general I think yeah most people in
your life you would say the woman that
you've never heard anything like she
wears the pants in the relationship no
no no no never heard that okay okay go
ahead
I'm sorry do you think men are respected
in society no
I don't I just I'm not in general
respects yes
um and obviously they should be but no
I've going back to the point I made
earlier about women
um listening to other women about what
it what we think men want if we listen
to men if we respected them this
wouldn't be an issue we would listen to
them we wouldn't be going to other women
and appeasing and competing with them
because we would know that's not even
what men want so if you respect them it
comes to honoring them listening to them
and Society does not reflect a general
overall population that respects men
because we aren't giving men what they
want men are complaining men are
desperate for women who respect them and
hear them and see them and we aren't
doing that so overall we don't respect
men
um I think majority of men are respected
in society
um even at situations in the gym you
might go to the gym and you're using
something and a man might come over
because you're a woman he kind of thinks
you can push you away or take your
weights or whatever what's he wouldn't
do that with a man maybe in certain
situations a woman wouldn't respect a
man is that common that's happened to me
yeah but I mean that's just in the gym
but just in general anyway like unless A
man gives you a reason not to respect
him then I think majority of the time
you would respect him so why do you
think we men are trash as a common
saying no matter the problem I know the
issue if most women respect men why do
we have those sayings I think there's
just kind of extremists that have gone
through situations where they have maybe
gone through a lot of times due to their
own fault because they're not learning
but and then they just take their anger
out on line making these expressions and
yeah just going forward with that so you
just think it's a minority I mean I
don't have that view on men because I
think if someone's trashed in their
trash that's just a personal thing and
there are quite a lot of people that say
that but that's kind of what's put out
to you you don't really see the nice
stuff nice stuff sometimes do you think
most women respect the average Tesco
worker the average KFC where I don't
know what you guys have here the chicken
the the chicken shop worker it's one
thing to average or it's one thing to
respect successful men and men in you
know high power positions but do you
think most women respect average men
um I think most decent women do just as
respecting a person though I um I have
an interesting story about that because
just the other day being in London not
being from here I um I always engage I'm
always friendly just talking to
different people and I had an
interesting conversation with my Uber
driver the other day and he was telling
me about how he he has a nice car he has
his own business and things like that
but he doesn't drive his nice car when
he's doing Uber right why would we put
run up the mouse on a nice car right and
he has had his eye on a particular girl
here in London and he he was telling me
that that's generally the culture here
when he goes out and he's in his plane
clothes and he's in his Uber Prius
driving around girls aren't trying to
give him play but because they had
mutual friends he ended up going out
with her one night when he was he had on
his Louis Vuitton bag and he had on he
had his nice car the same girl who was
ignoring him was giving him attention in
the time of day now and he literally
told her
you know you ignored me the other day
right and she tried to downplay it and
laugh it off like oh haha no not at all
and from the males that I have
encountered here
um I would say it's the same in the in
the US too as well from a lot of girls
you see them and he's looking bummy and
he because he Works Sanitation or
whatever the case may be and you're like
Ugh whatever
um and then when you see them in a
different setting now you want oh he has
something oh he's flashy now he's this I
would absolutely say that that is the
culture and I've heard it from men's
mouth that story just two days ago from
my Uber driver and I was like a pod I
was like are you serious he's like yeah
and I told her get away like
no like I have no interest in you now
you just ignored me you've been ignoring
me for months and now that we're out you
see my nice car you see my Rolex you see
that I have stuff you're interested now
uh what do you think do you think most
women respect most men I don't think
they do no there's a lot of women now
these days that just want to stand on
their own two feet because it's society
and that's just the way it is and I
think a lot of women won't build of a
man so if she sees him at his lowest a
woman doesn't want that
I think that's the wrong person either
yeah is that what you did you said you
had three kids yeah I was with my ex
from when I was 14 until I was 23. we
just didn't work out we still get along
you know we're amicable and that's it
unfortunately it just didn't work out
for us
it why not
um
because of a lot of women out here are
trash and they throw themselves because
they see a man doing his thing and he's
got nice things and he I think he was
just a weak man and he accepted that
there's a lot of things that I wouldn't
do in the bedroom that these women was
willing to do with him so I think that's
just yeah for these women who know that
he was in a relationship um a lot of
women yeah a lot of them did yeah do you
think that's something that could be
worked out like work past did you ever
try to um yeah we tried we tried for a
long time and we had a few beautiful
children you know why wouldn't we but
unfortunately I just couldn't get over
that I became paranoid I became
obsessing over these women that he
cheated on me with so it just didn't
work and I didn't want that environment
around my kids
um do you think most women respect most
men
um I think respectful women will respect
men but
not all obviously I'm asking most uh
probably not now no no
I think it's to do with the age
I think that
we're in my my age and older do
women younger than me
they don't and as for a young lady there
there's nothing no woman can do out
there to my man that ain't gonna do
myself
I'm doing everything I don't care
whether I've got to try and do handset
I'm disabled I would try and do a
handstand because no woman ain't gonna
have sex me with my man
there's nothing I'm going for the whole
okay I'm doing everything so when I hear
women say oh that woman was willing to
do things that I won't do for my man and
I'm thinking myself but
what is it that you wouldn't do for your
man do you think that goes to the lack
of submission with this generation I was
thinking the same thing but is that like
a submission thing where your man is
wanting something Desiring especially if
he's willing to communicate it and he's
not embarrassed by it I would be of the
nature that I'm a try to I might not be
the best but if you teach me a little
something we might get there anything
once it don't ever once it doesn't
involve a third party yeah what if he
did ask that then what if I'm announced
it pardon what if he asks me to do
something I'm gonna do it that's my man
I want to do I mean if he asks for a
third party is that where you draw the
line because you would know that in the
beginning because I'm all the only woman
he needs I can do everything okay I'll
even try I'll even try and double up
again I'm two people
no no no no no no that's what I said
okay there's a limit he knows the limit
and he's pushed the limit
but no
but I think that the younger people the
younger women they don't respect they
don't respect men and I think it's the
old bitter women that don't I mean me I
can say like I've never heard of any of
this before because most of my friends
are older than me like 10 15 years older
than me and they're like married people
but I know they've got some bitter old
women out there that will tell
youngsters I mean I've even had them
trying me but because I know that I've
got older women out there that got sense
and I think that
no I think that young people I think
that's where it's at that's where it's
gone wrong with the young people because
the old people won't tell them
and you get people my age that are still
going out they're trying to be young and
they're old it's not happening it might
depend on what kind of men you've had in
your life influence and growing up
growing up like I've got an amazing dad
and I've got amazing men in my family so
the respect for men is rooted there but
maybe if you have a either an absent
father or just I think that's a cop out
after all adults we're all adults we
know right from wrong and we decide what
to do because you can have people their
parents are murderers and everything
like that they can go out to be decent
human beings I think I think it plays
into the lack of healing that this
generation won't adapt to and admit
right so even if your dad wasn't there
even if you didn't have a male figure
even if you've gone through traumatic
dating experiences who does the
responsibility lie in for you to take
accountability and say okay I don't want
to be bitter and lash out against random
men who I don't even know who I've never
even encountered and when we're gonna
say I want to be a better person I want
to be a decent person to identify where
this is coming from and to do something
different if women are that unfunctional
they shouldn't be working they'll be out
there on the streets like tramps because
they're making all these excuses if
you've got the brain enough to go and do
a job you've got brain enough to sort
your life out there should be no excuse
because you're not stupid for the stupid
women go ahead
but I'm tired of hearing I did have this
I didn't have that
trauma healing get along you know what
but no it's a part of it though you just
you said it earlier right when you
talked about what what it took for you
to become the woman it took work and
women these days aren't trying to do the
work I had a conversation earlier and I
personally as I once I realized Lauren
had daddy issues Lauren went to the
table and Lauren dealt with daddy issues
and then I began to recognize that he
issues another woman and I would talk to
them and they would self-identify daddy
issues and I was shocked I was like wait
you know you have daddy issues because
if I had known earlier I would have
fixed some earlier I didn't know I had
that issue so until I fixed them but
there are women walking around knowing
that they are traumatized knowing that
they have gaps in them and they don't
want to address it because they don't
want to do the work it is hard work to
look inside of you and know that you
can't victimize yourself know that you
have to be accountable and to stand up
and say yeah my daddy did this he wasn't
present he wasn't whatever but that's
not on him I got to forgive him and I
have to realize what's that's done for
me and if I want a healthy relationship
the role the active role that I have to
play in evolving and becoming a better
person to get that and people don't want
to look in the mirror people do not want
to deal with themselves
can they do it for their bosses so
that's a lot of rubbish because women do
it for the if your boss said if you're
in the job and your boss said I want you
to train and do this then we'll go for
it everyone says you're doing this then
we weren't going to want to do it I mean
I just think we don't live in
we just get away with it because we
don't face consequences for anything
it's like there's so many Sims that'll
put up with disrespectful behavior and
still date them and still marry them
still give them children when they don't
respect them I mean how many times we
hear happy wife happy life how many
times do we hear she wears the pants in
the relationship is that a relationship
any woman really wants to be in where
she's exactly they end up divorcing them
and then we're in the same cycle when a
guy wants to make a decision like she'll
call him toxic and controlling I mean I
hear all the time on the show if he asks
you to take down your social media he's
toxic and controlling one that's
actually quite reasonable to not want
random men looking at your girl on the
Internet it's actually what you're
posting as well like if you're out here
with am I on your post and all these
like it depends what type of things that
you're posting I would feel if you're
just posting a picture every once a year
and like that pictures with your man or
with your family or with your friends
and you're not like being excessive
enough oh fine fair enough well if
you're out there posting like your tits
you're a buoy your body everything and
you're in a relationship you need to see
that you're actually the problem in that
relationship because you're getting the
view from the men you know what I mean
and you're putting yourself in that
light and men are going to like that
damn picture but the whole point of
submission is you don't ask him why yeah
we had a girl Maggie on the show and
they said he asked you to take down your
social media and she has the most mild
cooking stuff she just said it wouldn't
even be a conversation and so it's like
but it's so unheard of from women to
just listen to men not you know it's not
every man like don't listen to the
homeless man on the street
but you know what I'm saying
um MTR what do you think yeah um I mean
to just sum it up no like respect uh for
men is at a
um all-time low
um
I think that respect for men within our
society today is more so tied to what
that man can provide in the utility
within that like short story so um
before I started on YouTube
um I consider myself a hobbyist
um and so one of the things that I did
prior to turning the video camera on
myself is to become a photographer now
at the same time you know I was you know
post MBA working a six-figure job and a
fortune whatever company but I wanted to
do photography so I eventually started
to like book gigs
um within that one of the gigs that I
booked
um I it was at like a wedding party or
something like that
um and
and then I'm having a conversation with
a young woman at the wedding party I saw
a kind of look and I saw a kind of
choose and decided to walk up and have a
conversation with them and like the low
level barometer of disrespect
uh just based off of oh so you like is
this what you do like this little
photography thing and I was like oh you
dirty dirty wench that's what I was
thinking I didn't want to say it like
that just because like you know I was
gonna I was gonna get paid for the day
you know I don't want to cause a a
brouhaha within the establishment right
so you know just based off of being what
they consider to be an average earner or
an average worker a lot of that respect
is derived from there but you know
that's why I like on my channel I tell
so many of the men to continue to work
on you know yourselves and utility
within your life because people no one
owes you favors no one will care right
like men and women are judged within our
society off of different metrics right
but as a man you should know what the
metrics are judged off of and if you
choose to play well this is the cost of
that it is right as opposed to men that
go their own way so no there's not a um
a whole level of respect you know where
I also see it as well I see it outside
of the club when I see the young women
putting fingers in men's faces
where they're instigating fights because
of something that might have happened
inside of the club if you had a respect
for a man then you'd understand that a
man is more than likely stronger than
you and he could do damage to you equal
rights equal love he can do damage
clearly if he decided that he don't want
to play with your no more but
no this is not a level of respect
because if he respected a man that you
don't understand then you would respect
his hand strength his arm strength that
he's much bigger than you that's just
being smart
disrespectful people do dumb why do
you think people automatically think
that the woman's the victim when she
gets hit and when often times she hit
first women are looked at as fragile
little beings and oh you can't hit a
woman it's that woman out there saying
she wants to meet girls and they playing
it to that victim equal hit and it's not
even it's not even necessarily that you
put your hand on a guy women don't
understand the power of our influence
and our voice right it's how you talk to
a man right if you can stir up some
things in him and entice him in a way
that make him want to put his hand on
you and people will say oh it wasn't
justifiable because she didn't hit you
even though that's not appropriate
either but it's like women why are you
running your mouth like this to a man I
mean what's what's worse verbal abuse or
physical abuse I think I'm gonna say I'm
gonna say verbal for a man absolutely
who do you think verbally abuses the
other gender more about no women 100
percent
we also got to thank our media as well
like shout out to Oprah The Color Purple
um what she's done to the image of the
black man in society today uh and she's
completely right like everyone is just
walking around thinking that you know
men are just uh especially black men too
with Destroyers I didn't know actually I
didn't actually watch a lot of Oprah
growing up so like what what did she do
so specifically have no idea so so
specific to image uh image being
um formed within our media today
um I know we did the king Rich's podcast
not too long ago and we talked about
blackmail image and how um it's kind of
formed today and what it is and what I
said like what is the what is the image
of man uh black man you know within
America today and the first word that
came out was Thug
um I think some in other words was like
a beater or things like that right so
you know there's been images within
media that has promoted that we are big
bad tough strong and that you know women
can do no wrong women must be protected
out side of their behavior you know I I
think you know back to that respect
question that there's a certain behavior
of women that deserves more respect
right like of the women right like that
one-on-one that comes out is Maggie The
Substitute Teacher who's gracious with
his presence this past week you sit and
you talk to Maggie for like a little bit
Maggie was up in the kitchen for 12 damn
hours and I'm not saying that you gotta
be up in the kitchen but she she came in
to a place that she was unfamiliar with
and graced it with feminine ease and
presence her influence So within
feminine ease and presence guess what as
a man I am biologically driven to
protect that
biologically
it was just Villages it comes off of her
just afterwards I went up to her and I
was just like oh my goodness I love this
I want I want to be a part of this what
program so you have like I can sign up
for because it's just it's amazing it
literally changes the the whole
atmosphere when she talks it's a respect
everyone gets quiet you want to listen
to her you want to honor that and that's
that's what we need to push for women in
society because we need if we return to
that the power that is in that men would
naturally protect us and here's the
thing it's one thing to to say it but
um his eye because I was like to think
about about this earlier like how do I
because I I can say to you like listen
this based off of her presence it's just
like if something was to happen I'd be
like man you good
based off the aura in the room or
whatever that changed right so it's just
like how do we get more women in the
understanding of like that's what
femininity is that ease is I think it's
so rare because it's a failure on the
mother's part
I mean even from two parent households
you absolutely see a lack of femininity
in the in the mothers like how many how
many moms genuinely that you know if if
the husband made a decision a big
decision for the household that she did
not agree with she would just say okay
yes sir
no absolutely
that's pushing it sir
I don't I don't for me personally I'll
speak to that right and my mom is
amazing super sweet loving as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible